(audience applauds and cheers)
- I mean,
(Arsema laughs)
I don't have long enough with
you and I'm sad about it.
(Arsema laughs)
But I'm, so, we're all fans
of "Bridgerton" in general.
Just, before even this show existed,
but I have to tell you,
this series gets better.
I watched the first series, I was like,
"No way they're gonna do
it with the second one."
I was like, "Oh my God!"
(Arsema laughs)
"No way they're gonna do
it with the third one."
This is my favorite one.
- [Arsema] No way!
- It is--
- Wow!
- So, no, no, way, way, way.
It is so good.
So tell us,
or I know who you play,
but tell everybody who you play
and like what it's really
about your character?
- So I play a young Queen Charlotte.
Queen Charlotte is obviously,
the queen in "Bridgerton".
So I play the younger version
of Golda Rosheuvel's portrayal of her.
- [Corey] There she is.
- [India] There she is!
- Oh my God!
(audience applauds and cheers)
looking phenomenal.
- She's pretty cool.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And that's her.
She's pretty, yeah, she's
17, has come from Germany.
- Kind of a progressive mind for the time.
- [India] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [India] Completely.
- And very kind of inquisitive
and really lovely to play
someone who's not just one-dimensional.
She's got so many different layers
and yeah, very, very lucky
to be a part of it and to play her.
- And it's intense.
Y'all's different, yeah,
I was like, "What?"
- [India] Yeah.
- Okay
tell everybody who's here, Lady Danbury?
- Yes!
- [Kelly] Your version.
- Yeah, I'm young Lady
Agatha Danbury in the show.
You kind of see her
in a much different
version than you saw in--
(audience applauds and cheers)
(laughs) Yes, yeah!
So like in "Bridgerton",
she's this extremely
powerful woman, you know,
you see her with her cane and her hat.
And then to see her in this
show, she is just not there yet.
And you kind of see her become that.
So to see what a journey is like
in a young black woman is
so just exciting to play.
- And the pressure and the weight.
I love how this story,
it has a lot of parallels
for just like life now too, you know?
And there's a lot of messaging in there.
Not in a way that beats you over the head,
but tells a story to where you
make, it's thought provoking.
- Yeah.
- I just love how you see her
in a completely different light, you know?
You did a great job.
- [India] Didn't she?
- It was really, really great.
Yes.
- Thank you. (giggles)
(audience applauds and cheers)
Corey, you can tell everybody
who you play, but oh my gosh.
I feel like you, out of
the entire cast, just,
they put you through the
wringer emotionally, like.
- Yeah. Yeah. It wasn't easy.
- [Kelly] No.
- Yeah. these guys made
it very easy, easier.
- Yeah.
Not so much India.
(all laughing)
No, no, no.
No, it was great, yeah.
He is charming, he has
that string to his bow,
but he, the man that he, there he is.
- Yeah King George.
- Yeah.
(audience applauds and cheers)
- Sorry, that,
I wasn't asking.
- And you play King George,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just looking fantastic.
Here's the thing, I know
y'all all look beautiful
and gorgeous and whatever.
How uncomfortable were you?
Don't lie. (chuckles)
- Me and Arsema are like, where
do we go, where do we start?
- Yeah, there's so many choices.
The shoes, the skirts
themselves were heavy.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- The corsets and then the wigs.
- Yeah, yeah yeah.
- Which were like another good 10 pounds.
- I mean, they did a great
job. You look incredible.
But I was like,
there is no way they're
not crying deep inside.
(Arsema laughs)